we're here at Comic-Con and I cannot I'm
I can't be more thrilled to be with the
cast creators showrunners of For All
Mankind I've said it again and again
online uh this is one of my favorite
shows on any channel I can't recommend
the show enough I really love what you
guys do and I I know how hard it is to
make a TV show and I really appreciate
the hard work the long hours everything
you do to make this show happen and a
big thank you to Tim Cook and apple I've
[ __ ] myself out as hard as I can now
let's actually get Steve his iPhone now
look at that one in so we're we're at
Comic-Con and I believe is this your
first time with the show at Comic-Con so
this basically tells me Apple really
believes in the show so who's gonna tell
me yeah so who's gonna tell me that the
fourth season renewal has happened uh I
am right
because there's no doubt they brought
the show down here to be like three
seasons and we're done absolutely
correct Yeah a hundred percent the show
is still airing its third season for
fans what can you actually tease about
what's coming up um in the rest of the
third season what I will say is that
um almost every episode's ending feels
like a season finale the scope of these
last four episodes are just massive we
we've really tried to outdo ourselves
and I think we we might have just pulled
it off I've seen the eight of the ten
and and you have I really really love
this third season it's the best one you
guys have done when you were making it
as actors did you did you feel like oh
this is really some great writing this
is fantastic I want to add something
because I'm horrible at reading like
stage directions like you're like the
ship does this and does this and I'm
like I can't visualize this at all and
there was so much of that so honestly
when I watch the episodes that's
probably the first time I registered
what the season even was and and I
thought they were great so so so yeah so
when I watched it I thought it was great
yeah and I feel the same as Coral like I
remember you know I watched the episodes
early to prepare for the podcast and so
I was watching the end of episode three
and we cut to Joel and the Helios and
he's firing her up and then we cut to
the uh Sojourner and Black Hole Sun just
swoops in and I just wept I was like I
can't believe we made this like we
actually did this it it worked we pulled
it off and so much like Coral like you
read it and you have a vision of it and
then when you're making it you're in the
you're in the nitty-gritty or in the
kitchen doing it but then once you step
back and see it you're like this is
remarkable it's just something so
special also the thing is like the VFX
are incredible and some of the outer
space stuff when there's maybe disasters
that happen I'm like Jesus it's like a
movie yeah and honestly we that's how we
look at it like I think Jay and Barbara
or VFX people like when we started the
show we're like we don't want this we
want this to have the quality of a movie
of a going going to theater experience
because I think that's where television
is at this point you kind of have to
match that level if not you know
exceeded even and I think yeah it's a
testament to what they do because you
know when we start every year in the
room
our ideas are crazy like we go for it
and then we realize it takes 10 episodes
the actors the visual effects every
Department to really pull that off by
the end of the year and and we've done
it so far so
I have not asked you this question I've
asked these uh gentlemen right here what
season do you think will be where the
show gets to being on a Starship
I mean
season three I mean it's kind of a
Starship that is true right no no
there's definitely a Starship in season
three but I mean you know when you start
because listen Ronald Moore is involved
in this he might have some history with
Star Trek and that kind of a thing you
know a little bit so I'm wondering when
it becomes like a Starship show do you
know I'm joking around but not really
like season five season season 13 14
we'll get we'll get there yeah so I I
like learning about the behind the
scenes the making of the show you guys
have answered this already but we have
some newcomers to the collider answer on
this one what do you think for fans of
the show they'd be surprised to learn
about like the actual making of the show
Chris has has put some stuff on social
media that can can show that before
we're in a we're in a warehouse with
green screens and and we don't even
sometimes have the visors on you know
that when you're on in space because the
reflections of the cameras and stuff so
we're we're making this and it's just
like it it's Bare Bones and there's a
lot of love and a lot of Hope and a lot
of dreams but we don't know how it's
gonna land and so a lot of um if they if
people saw the before they'd be amazed
by the after I mean what's created even
the the creative choices of you know
when everyone's uh going to Mars and the
zoom ins on on Sojourner and and Helia
The Helio ship and all that it's it's
it's it's it's so amazing the the the
creativity that goes into this I mean I
I you see it but you don't see it until
you see the before and then you go holy
crap you know it's really one of those
kind of experiences when you know when
so much of the world is created
digitally so for us you know we're
walking around there like you know
waddling Teletubbies and in this green
in this green room and then when you
watch it it's you're on Mars you're like
there's caverns and mountains and and
space and uh so it's it's very cool to
see like these things that you sort of
Imagine a little bit and then all of a
sudden it comes to life I mean those are
one of the the magic aspects of what we
do and I gotta give credit to the cast I
mean when you're acting in that
situation where you don't have the ship
you don't it's green it's the surface
isn't fully there but what they're able
to do by making it feel real makes our
jobs Easier by filling in the gaps later
you know I think you always believe
they're in that situation I think it's a
testament to them so I'm very curious
what where are you in terms of are you
shooting season four right now like when
you start production a couple of weeks
right three weeks yeah months yeah I'll
move on to something else I'm curious
for you guys where are you in the
writing process of season four have you
like do you have like the finale figured
out do you have the full outline like
where are you in the writing process
we're kind of in the in the think of it
right yeah yeah
we're actually after this we're gonna go
keep working on the scripts in between
interviews so
um no we're in the middle of it you know
our our show is constantly uh evolving
and sometimes we'll get to the end and
realize oh we actually need to go we
have this great idea for the finale now
we gotta go back to episode 5 and start
setting that up so
um yeah we're in the middle of it and
it's uh
it's gonna be a whole new ball game as
every season is one of the things that I
love about the show one of the many
things obviously is that we're watching
essentially like people's entire lives
as the seasons progress which is so
unusual on a show to be able to portray
characters growing like this
um so for all the actors can you sort of
talk about that aspect of being you know
what I mean like it's a full life
a dream like as an actor you hope to
play
um a young black girl in an all-white
environment and a post-civil Rights era
or you hope to play a widow who is
trying to put her life back together or
you hope to play a astronaut Commander
who's you know telling everybody what to
do and has their [ __ ] together so to get
to do all of those things year after
year after year you're just like pinch
me like this is insane that I get to do
this and I think for me I feel like I've
grown as Danielle has grown like in the
beginning I came in and kept saying to
these guys like I don't know I don't
know if I'm like doing this right and
then as time went on like I got my sea
legs that's Danielle got her sea legs
and I think you know it's just like I'm
excited for all of us to continue to to
play these long Journeys and revisit
these characters again and wonder like
do I still have her in me you know
because of the pandemic and because of
the the time of the way in which we
shoot it it's been a year since I played
her last so it's like where is she how
can I find her again and then you meet
her 10 years when you saw her a blast so
it's just really lovely and the other
cool thing about you know working with
all these guys we're really working with
Joel is like we always have each other
we always have that friendship that
relationship that we can Bond you know
come back to and so whatever nerves you
have applying this character year after
year you lean on the folks you do it
with and you guys do it together you
know
yeah well I'll definitely step in it's
been so gratifying starting you know
Kelly as like a 17 year old telling her
parents her dreams and getting feisty
about it and also lying to her co-stars
and like listen I had to play a child
okay and you and Chantel are too hot and
like young looking so we had to work
with what we were given
um but no it's just been so fun to play
adult Kelly and stand straight and tall
and confident and walk into that room
with Commander pool and and tell her I'm
the one for the job Andy Freeman can go
kick rocks you know poor Andy but yes it
is so incredibly gratifying as an actor
to be able to revisit these characters
and grow with them
um and be given insane scenarios to to
play with
um I I mean it's funny sometimes when we
you know I have a meeting with Matt and
Ben and we the the hardest part is we
want it to be different you know we want
the 10 years you to see the 10 years but
it can't be too much that you're
suddenly like that's a completely
different person the fun part of when I
joined in season two was that Elena went
through so much that she sort of was a
different person and I got kind of lucky
there
um but but after that you're it's the
it's the in-between of how do we show
that that 10 years can really change
someone yeah but I I really think that
you do become a different person yeah
totally yeah that's sort of how I
approached it that you you actually
changed so much and there is like
literature that supports that that we
actually like in 10 years our
personalities change so much that we
actually in effect become a different
person and I think anyone that looks
back and thinks of themselves who you
were 10 years ago and if you'd meet that
person you'd put that person next to you
now it would feel like a different
person I'm pretty much the same actually
I'm except foreign
[Laughter]
yeah no I think for me it was really it
was really challenging and Danny I feel
like definitely changes from when we see
him from season two he's kind of more of
a upbeat fun human being and then it's
just it gets into this very uh intense
place so it was a very challenging
experience but also incredibly exciting
I mean that's what you dream about as an
actor is to take on these challenges and
do it
um so jumping 10 years and not being
not knowing if you're going to be able
to do it and then doing it and feeling
good about it and yeah moving on yeah
Casey I mean Casey had a
a heavy arc on this on this season it
was like a lot a lot uh Weighing on his
shoulders and uh he killed it yeah I
just wanted to know real quick because
Danny makes some very questionable
choices sure uh and what is it like as
an actor playing someone who's what the
person's doing you really might disagree
with
um yeah I mean
in that moment you have to justify it
and justify it and just be that it's
like this is what's happening and yeah
it's difficult because you don't I don't
know if Danny even really realizes that
he's like making these bad decisions
like things are just happening all at
once in all of these emotions and past
is just coming up and coming out of him
um so doing it is just yeah it's it's
it's difficult but not agreeing with it
is
it's a part of the job and you just have
to you have to commit to it and go full
for it so yeah and it's also I mean we
throw around these words like you know
[ __ ] you know a lot but it's
rarely that it like really
you know it's true it's far an actual
father [ __ ] that's me did you know
that I did I did
before before we wrap um I just have to
say that uh on my panel later is Andrew
Stanton and I'm friends with Andrew and
he wanted to be here I don't know if
he's if he managed to make it he did not
so I'm just going to say if you guys can
quickly just say hi Andrew because I'm
gonna give him the video
um we won't say hi Andrew we'll say
Happy Thanksgiving
Happy thanks happy sorry I missed that I
understand Thanksgiving oh [ __ ]
sorry I was uh still thinking about my
successful joke
[Laughter]
so for everyone watch es right now I
really want to say one more time uh if
you're not watching this show for the
love of [ __ ] god watch this show and
I'm sorry for cursing but it was worth
it
um thank you guys so much and have a
fantastic Comic-Con thanks a lot thanks
a lot